[Música]
nación más del 100% de las crisis
personas suicidas que realmente siguen el
crisis sanitaria es lo que se entiende por
te suicidaste con estos aumentos en
intentos de suicidio o calificación
por lo tanto pensamientos suicidas para prevenir
los jóvenes
[Música]
su parte es agradable en absoluto realmente
sin hambre no salgas de sus paredes horas
y en especial para los delfines de los que tengo
necesito el 20 de junio frente a la gente vaya
llevarnos a ver el punto de libertad del ser
nombrados son por desgracia cierto que somos
finalmente bloqueó todo opus missillier
mas banana y por ultimo modificar la i
ver Escribo idioma tiempo
[Música]
Y
así de repente vinimos porque ayer
ella hizo comentarios inquietantes a la
la universidad es en realidad ella la quería
quería morir y ella quería huir de
la casa
hay veces que no se siente
Bueno, hay momentos en que ella
hasta me echa la culpa por no verla mas
que le importa porque el agua lo que
la estacion
[Música]
mi